now empowering young girls and future
leaders in our community yeah women
united is an organization that needs
your help to fund a variety of local
programs which includes scholarships for
local students hector mahia live this
morning near jones in flamingo where a
volunteer project's just getting started
hector good morning to you sir
hey there good morning guys and we have
an assembly line here going on and
they've been here throughout the morning
and these boxes will not only contain
items from local businesses owned by
women but they also have
a very special mission behind them and
it's all to help people here in our
community
joining us live we have april franks to
talk to us not just about the mission
but let's start with this tell us about
your involvement with the organization
and the event yes yes so my name is
april franks and i am the president and
ceo of april
and companies and we are the empowerment
sponsor
and we are so excited to be able to
support such an event that's supporting
women right here
in our local area tell us why why is
this so important for you
it's important to me because women
influence a lot of decisions
on the planet and the more empowered we
are the more educated we are the more
connected we are then we can do really
amazing things starting with ourselves
with our families that bridges out into
the communities and then that really
helps
shape our world and i think that's
something that we should all be standing
up for
awesome we have a lot of cool items here
tell us about the event coming up
in just about two weeks is that correct
yes april 23rd mark your calendars at 4
pm
we have an amazing box here that was
done by the signature suite
and all of these are the majority of
these items were donated
and sponsored by local women businesses
right here
in the southern nevada area i believe
the number was
95 yes so that's an a
that's an a and not only that that's a
plus
and not only that but what's great is
these women in business
they will get all of this amazing
exposure and people will know that they
exist
and they can potentially do business
with them all of this is to empower
women and girls so we can spread
all of this goodness around and i think
it's a good thing
the event is going to be um supporting
women and
young girls and helping them with their
education and who doesn't want to get
behind that
right and we all have a very important
woman in our life
absolutely or many like figures mothers
sisters grandmothers
absolutely like i said when you shape a
woman you empower her you really
do something really special and i think
the more of these types of events that
we can do
in working with the united way the
better and make sure
you grab your ticket it's a virtual
ticket so no matter where you
are on the planet where your family is
you can go to
uw sn dot org
and grab a virtual seat and grab a vip
seat because that will enable you to
capture this box and to get access to
all these goodies
vip for very important thank you very
much so
we'll be posting a link on how you can
get involved on our website
eightnewsnow.com for now reporting live
hector mejia
and april franks back to you guys